yes we're back folks joining me now is
the man
responsible for popeel's pocket
fisherman the vegimatic the smokeless
ashtray
and that spray paint for balding men
please welcome folks ron popio
good to see you you didn't mention mr
microphone or the smoke massage tray or
kind of circular broom or miracle brush
that's right you also invented all these
other things now let me ask you
something about you invented mr
microphone yes
was it your idea in the advertisement
for mr microphone
the line hey good looking i'll be back
to pick you up later is that your you
thought of that line
that's genius that's genius for my
generation how about the problem with
buttons is they always fall off
and when they do don't sew them on the
old-fashioned way use a needle and
thread
your your lines your lines are part of
america's consciousness
they really are in an incredible way you
also did uh
it slices and it dices it cuts a cow in
half and that's no bulb
have you written any books that you know
books of these phrases
well they're doing a book right now oh
they're doing a serious book but you
could just write like a whole book of
just these phrases
well at least a half a page oh well this
is let me let me ask you about the glh
spray what does glh stand for it's an
amazing
great looking hair okay when i heard
about this for the first time
of course i'm such an idiot and there's
nothing to see there
forget it forget it uh the glh spray now
when i first heard about this i thought
it was a joke you're balding so you take
some black spray paint and just cover it
and
voila yeah it's more than that is it not
it's a
yeah it's a it's a great great product i
got to show you how it works though
that's that's what i'd love to do now
show you how it works all right show me
how it works yeah it's um
actually i got the idea from raymond but
uh
are we gonna do something in your yeah
yeah we actually have a band member
who's well he's a little thinning on top
la bamba come here
and then and then i want you oh we'll
take care of that
first let's turn around and show
everybody let's see the problem here you
can see my bald spot also
but they're cute together it's nice
let's do this real fast okay now can i
ask what is in here because he's a band
member of mine and i feel responsible
what is actually in gla it's something
that's going to make him disappear you
wanted to get rid of him didn't you
mason i'll do the jokes
[Laughter]
let's do this let's do this fast it's
why it's called glh number nine what was
wrong with
one through eight what happened it
didn't work too good so the night the
night time it worked
okay okay go oh my god no this is not
dark
it's burning his flesh off beautiful
look at that ben look at that that's
amazing no it's not amazing
when does the steam go away
it looks like an irish moor all right
that's nice and then you cover it over
yeah
that's amazing yeah it's real hair
what do you think folks that's amazing
now
[Applause]
all right here we go right here anywhere
there's a bald spot okay
okay no we need more that's enough no i
think we need everything
that's enough i could tell it's enough
all right i just thought
and what happens well we'll get rid of
actual hair my god it works
how's that look that's great
that's very nice okay
you won't say what's in it actually is
it just liquefied hair have you
it's a powder that builds on itself now
what happens if you go out in the rain
it doesn't wash out i mean it washes out
with any shampoo but it won't
come off if you exercise running out in
the rain
i feel like an infomercial shell but if
you go to sleep what happens if it rains
uh well but i could never afford this
uh how much does it cost 19.95
1 843
for this i'd pay as much as four hundred
dollars
what it comes with a cap my god all
right
now i understand you have a new
invention here this actually turns pasta
into hair
this makes it makes hairy pasta oh okay
but you're going to make pasta you've
never made pasta before have you i've
never had pasta this good
here put some flour in here will ya
all right fill it up fill it with flour
yeah
all the way to the top all the way to
the top all right am i wasting time on
my batteries
they're wasting time oh sorry they said
they only had 63 seconds for me
okay here you go just throw it down you
have to do that just dump it in just
dump it in here dump it in all right an
idiot could do that
right all right next thing you
say it like it is okay take an egg and
we'll put an egg in here
okay okay put some olive oil in there
spray
not yet not oh well hey put it in
all right just a shot okay all right
some olive oil my god it's working here
too put some olive oil in will ya i made
a baby all right okay
put some olive oil in there fine okay
then what happens
this is an amazing cup it has a pin in
it and when you shake it like this
it actually blends everything together
because of the pen
yeah you don't have to use a fork in a
bowl to get everything messed up now we
have some
normally you use water but instead of
water we'll use a little v8 juice
you put v8 juice in there yeah because
we're going to make tomato pasta like
oh i see and just put it up to the lime
right like so and that v8 juice is
available in any supermarket
um only on tuesdays all right okay we'll
close the lid down okay shake this so we
get the color that we want and all the
nutrients are in there
okay turn the machine on okay
and we'll just pour this in here like so
wow
that's incredible wait a second it's not
done yet oh sorry
now what happens now huh well that's all
there is to it it becomes an icky goo
yes yes that runs for about another 10
or 12 seconds
okay and then just push the button all
the way down on the other side
and you'll have pasta what button all
the way down the other side
this one was it black huh yes push it
all the way down now push it all the way
down here we go
that's it yeah now what oh well watch
what happens
my god it's amazing
[Applause]
easy
hey look pasta is coming out pasta in
under two minutes
pretty simple that's amazing if your
water's bombing your sauce is already
made
that's incredible wait oh it has a
cutoff also look at that
that actually cuts the pasta freeing it
from the machine
very nice that's a great invention
thank you before we go we're out of time
but what's next what's next for uh mr
popeya what amazing invention is next
new product called pantomatic it's a
that product that you showed earlier you
think that could actually work
i think if they put an edition of toilet
paper on it
you got a winner you and i are going to
make so much money together yeah god
love you
thanks so much his name is ron from give
him a hand everybody
we'll be right back with andy kindler
i'll see you in a second